foreign
[Music]
at this section I'm going to share with
you our experience in using Multiplex
immunofluorescent Technologies to
support immune oncology studies the
title of my talk is deep profiling and
the spatial characterization of tumor
microenvironment using multi-ohmics
I am Ching Yang AO from neodynamics
Laboratory
here's the outline of my talk today
I will start with brief introduction on
the multiplex immunoflu fluorescence or
Multiplex if in this section we will
cover what is Multiplex if at the
advantage of using Multiplex if assays
especially to support immune oncology
studies
a new genomics we have used Multiplex if
essays to support exploratory
translational and clinical research for
10 years in the next session I would
share with you in some of the use case
and application of Multiplex if
so we will now Start begin with the
overview
conventional IEC has long been regarded
as the gold standard of tissue pathology
however the diagnostic and practicing
value of IHC could be restricted by
certain factors
for instance insufficient availability
of the clinical samples oftentimes the
clinical sample are using but biopsy
samples that can be small and also the
restricted labeling potential for the
IHC we oftentimes stain one biomarker
potential section
so the emergency of multiplexing
Technologies really provide us an
opportunity to overcome these challenges
then what is Multiplex technology then
so Technologies are really allowed the
simultaneous detection of multiple
markers on one single tissue section
it can be chromogenic or fluorescent
based
we will focus on the fluorescent-based
ones today
some of the height Multiplex or hyper
flux fluorescent platform enables
staining of more than 100 biomarkers
from one section
then what are the advantage of Multiplex
if what additional information Multiplex
if can provide by enabling staining of
such a large panel of biomarkers from
one single slide
here's one example to use Multiplex if
for immuno phenotyping and the spatial
interrogation of tumor microenvironment
or tme
I'm sure many of you are pretty familiar
with this cartoon here
we all know tumor microenvironment is
important to the development and
progression of tumors
a tumor can change its microenvironment
and the microenvironment can affect how
our tumor growth and spreads
the interaction between the tumor cells
and the immune system is an important
feature for the prognosis and treatment
of cancer
tumor microenvironment is composed of
complicated network with many critical
players a few examples are less in the
cartoon here such as mdsc that stands
for myeloid derived suppressor cell
tumor social microphages all these are
immunosuppressive cell types and known
to be important in promoting suppressive
tumor microenvironment that lead to
tumor immune evasion
it's important to be able to study and
monitor these cells during disease
progression and treatment
one feature of these cells these cells
share in common is that a set of
biomarkers are required in order to
correctly phenotype these cells
one of the example is mdsc
four biomarkers are needed to phenotype
mdncs including cd11b cd14 cd15 and hldr
same thing for tumor social microfages
different different subtypes of
dendritic cells as listed here in the
representative overlay so this makes a
perfect case for Multiplex assay since
the acid allows staining of all the spy
markers while in one slide therefore it
offers an ambiguous immune phenotyping a
single cell level enable the researchers
to precisely characterize all the cell
population within the tumor
microenvironment
in addition to phenotyping accumulative
evidence start to show the spatial
contacts is also very critical not just
only about how many cells present also
where the cells locate and the spatial
correlation between different cell
population within the tumor
microenvironment
spatial analysis is another sweet spot
of strength for Multiplex assay since
different cell population can be
sustained from one slide
and the biggest
immunophenotyping through co-expression
colocalization and the spatial
interrogation offered by Multiplex if
provides unique value in this case and
make it a robust approach to use to
support immune oncologist research
a number of Highly multiplied tissue
Imaging Technologies have emerged
introduced and adopted in both research
and clinical settings
some of the examples are listed here in
this slide
one thing might be worth pointing out is
that in addition to the fluorescent base
there are also other methodology such as
massback based technology so for example
the mibi the multiplex ion beam image
technology Imaging mastodometry or
belong to this category
for the presentation today I'm going to
focus is a fluorescent-based cycling
technology that is called multiomix
and this technology is actually one of
the earliest technology and has been
used at our lab for 10 years since its
deployment in 2013.
module mix is a fluorescent-based
multiplex technology that allows
detection of a large panel of biomarker
from one single ffp tissue
in the pns paper published in 2013 it
was demonstrated staining of over 60
proteins from one single ffp slide
for many of our ongoing projects we
oftentimes Run 10 to 30 biomarkers
assays
this is a very powerful tool for
comprehensive analysis of tumor biology
next let's quickly go over the multiple
mix technology workflow
the biomarkers in a module mix panel are
staying in sequential order with
conjugate antibodies
after each round of staining the stain
Imaging will be acquired
the slide would then go through
proprietary dye activation process to
Crunch the dye and erase the fluorescent
signals
then the slide will be placed on the
scanner to image again to make sure the
signals from previous round are
completely erased and also serve as the
Baseline for the next round of staining
the staining Imaging erase Imaging
process will be repeated until every
biomarker in the panel is stained
the biomarker staining for each antibody
in the panel is acquired from the same
regions same set of cell population
therefore can be easily overlaid
together to characterize the FIP sample
a single cell level
the one image on the left here is a
representative seven color overlay in a
resection tissue
module mix process is compatible with
resection samples tmas and clinical
biopsy samples
after the staining is completed for all
the biomarkers the Imaging analysis will
start
a new genomics we have internal develop
deep learning based Imaging analysis
pipeline called neolithics and this
pipeline is optimized to detect
fluorescent signal from multi-ohmics
platform and use for biomarker
quantification and the spatial analysis
after we now we know how multiomix works
we are now then look at examples how to
use module mix acids or panels to
characterize the tissues at single cell
level
the first example is the multiple mix
two panel to characterize the tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes within the
tumor micro environment
as listed here in this Slide the panel
includes a total of 12 markers with 11
immune oncology markers and one tumor
marker
with these 12 markers we actually can
detect many variety of phenotypes in the
tissues
as some of the examples are also
included here listed in the table
for instance
the T Hopper T cells can be detected by
co-expression of CD3 and CD4
and T cytotoxic cells can be detected by
co-expression of CD3 and cd8 and the
next we can use some color overlays to
see how this works
here's representative staining of a two
color overlay of pen CK and the CD3
tumor cells are stained with pen CK and
which that is Q2 colored in yellow here
so the large yellow cells indicate where
the tumors are with example
dd3 is General T cell biomarker
pseudo-colored in red this case and so
it stains all the where all the T cells
are so as you can see most of the T
cells located in the stroma surrounding
the tumor while there are a few of them
actually infiltrating under the tumor
areas
further characterize the T Cell
population in this tissue we can add CD4
CD4 is a marker for T helper cells in
this case a zero color in green
since both CD3 and CD4 membrane staining
the helper T cells will be positive for
both CD3 and CD4 and then they showing
yellow as you can clearly see here in
the zooming pick images the small size
of yellow cells indicate CD4 positive T
cells
now if now we actually add CDH in blue
and this allows us to detect cytotoxic T
cells for the T cytotoxic cells they
express both C3 and cd8 and here because
they're both membrane they will start to
show magenta color
and you can see by this approach most of
the T cells are categorized into helper
T cell and the cytotal T Cell population
in the slide
then now we if you are interested in
understand uh regular T cells we can use
a biomarker fox C3 and this biomarker is
a specific biomarker for regular T cells
and show a nucleus morphology
so the regular T cells here Express CD3
CD4 and fox 3. and shown yellow membrane
and with red nucleus as you can see the
examples here in the zooming images
now we can go to a seven Plex example we
now included both pdl1 and cd6a
cd60a is a general microfage marker and
this case in cyan color and pdo1 to the
card in pink magenta color
so pdl1 can express in both tumor cells
or immune cells
in this specific example by this
Multiplex approach we can easily tell
that pdo1 is immune cell stains immune
cell in this tumor by co-localides with
cd6a the microfage marker
further we can see the pdo1 positive
microphages
actually located in the stroma
surrounding the tumor
so again we we are able we were able to
characterize different immune phenotypes
within the fap section using the two
module Miss tool panel and also we have
a better understanding of the spatial
context of these cells
now let's go through another example
here
so here is an example of a non small
cell lung cancer nscoc and here shows is
what we call virtual HC of the sample
the virtual HD is a simulated he using
fluorescent signals the advantage here
is really to be able to view the
morphology from the same slide that used
for Multiplex staining and to enable the
pathologist to annotate the tissue
directly used for Multiplex staining so
you can see a lot of each green box here
and each green box is actually an area
picked biopathologist
all the tumor areas in this sample are
included for Multiplex staining and
Analysis
we now use this yellow area as an
example to see how we can characterize
it using multi-ohmics panel
so this is a full color overlay to
evaluate regular T cells and this is
Penske CD3 CD4 and epoxy3
so pency case things tumor cells and the
pseudo color included in this example
and as we discussed earlier regular T
cells Express CD3 CD4 and the fox P3 and
show as a yellow membrane and this case
magenta nucleus so you can see most of
the regular T cells are located in
stroma there are a few of them as
pointed out by the magenta error that
they're actually infiltrating into the
tumor boundary so you can clearly view
them by this uh by this in the overlay
images
the same region of the same region
that's with different tumor markers are
showing here
so this is to study pdoy expression
so pdo1 is pseudo color in green here
and two are still labeled as blue so in
this example the pdl1 Expresses in both
tumor cells as co-expressed with pen CK
and also immune cells as co-localized
with the microfiche marker cg68
so this multiplexer approach allows to
further quantify pdo1 expression in
different subtype of cells and also
using this approach more biological
question can be addressed and studied
after we go through how to use Multiplex
if panel to characterize the cells
within the tumor microenvironment now
I'm going to share one example how to
use these panels to support drug
discovery
this is the clinical trial we did in
2002 for byline and the results were
published in the intermedicine 220. in
this study they conducted a phase 2A
clinical trial to assess the efficacy of
immune combination therapy of the cxcr4
antagonist with anti-pd1 in the patients
with metastatic pdac refracted to one or
more previous line of chemotherapy
the used motium is teal and myeloid
panels to analyze different subtypes of
immune lymphocytes and myeloid cells
within the tumor microenvironment in
response to the treatment
the different sub phenotypes that can be
studied are as listed in the table
as shown here what they find is that the
cxcr for antagonist monotherapy and the
combination therapy increased
infiltration of different subtypes of T
cells including CD4 passive huberty
cells and CDA positive cytotoxic T cells
and also activated grenzyme B expressing
cytotoxic T cells they also
they also showed decreased numbers of
the suppressive GM dncs
trigger C in this example show one
example to demonstrate these changes
within the tumor microenvironment
in the treated sample so when you
actually see this see in the overlay and
in the treated sample you can see there
increase the number of different T
subtype of T cells when compared to the
Baseline sample and in this case the
patient experience clinical benefits of
this treatment
in addition to the lymphocytes and the
myeloid cells we have already many other
panels actually verified for immune
oncology use to identify different
immune population
some of the examples are listed here and
in addition to the solid tumor the
multiplexing panels and approach can
actually be also used for in
hematological malignancy indications as
well and we have also done some
exploratory work there
so in the last example I'm sure what I
shared is how to use Multiplex assay
especially multi-ohmics to perform
single cell level classification in the
tumor samples
wind can now look at another application
to use Multiplex immunoplarescence to
characterize morphologic structures such
as tertiary Ling voice structure TOS
within the tumor microenvironment
social info structure otos have been
identified in several solid tumor types
and associated with different uh
associated with different better
survival when present in the tumor
microenvironment
POS are composed of various immune cell
types and expect a variable degree of
maturation including early TOS that is
the immature type primary follicle like
TOs and secondary follicle TOs
being a large-scale retrospective
analysis of three independent cohorts of
cancer patients who were treated with
anti-pd1 or antipetal antibodies it has
been demonstrated that the presence of
the maturity OS was associated with the
improved objective response rate to
checkpoint Inhibitors and overall
survival
the data was published in nature cans in
2021 in this paper the author actually
developed and used the five Plex
Multiplex assay as shown in the figure
here
and the suggested that the majority of
explanation may be crucial for an
effective anti-tumor immune response
this is another application for
Multiplex assay
foreign
here's an internal study we did at
neogenomics using molecule mix the goal
was to characterize different stages
TOS in colorectal cancer patient samples
in this study we stained a 17 Plus
multi-ohmics panel in 40 CRC samples
with known MSI MMR status
the 17 Plex panel allows us to explore
TLS maturation stage
we can also evaluate other biomarkers
such as video1 expression and study
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes within
the tumor microenvironment along with
TOS maturation
using this panel we successfully
detecting and characterize different
stage of TOS in the CRC samples
examples of different stages of TOS
characterized by multiple mix as shown
in the slide here
the one above is the example for early
TOs
and the one below is a prime is a
primary follicle TOs
so for each of the example the virtual
he and the color overlay image are
provided side by side
so virtual HC again is giving us the
morphology information
and the lymphocyte Aggregates can be
clearly characterized using Multiplex
assay
in the example Above This is early TOs
and this is the immature type and you
can see the lingual size Aggregates here
by color overlay you can see it's
passive for T Cell sustained by CD3 B
cell indicated by cd20 and also positive
for pnad which is thanks for
high-endocilia venue so they capture the
features of the early TOs
and the example below so in addition to
CD3 cd20 and pnid this TOS also positive
for cd21 and indicating follicle
formation so this is a prima follicle
TOs
the more examples are shown here for uh
STS this is the secondary follicle TOs
and this is the maturity OS
so in this type of TOS the the TOs
actually are positive for cd23 and this
showing Active germinal Center formation
so by different biomarkers expression we
successfully characterize the different
stage of TOs
and the quantification was also
performed this case using neolithics
Imaging analysis algorithm
as a summary what's interesting is the
toss the mature stos is significant high
in the MSI CRC patients then MSS patient
the MS group
so this example definitely showed the
advantage of the multiplex I left acid
as well so in addition to single cell
phenotyping it's also a powerful tool to
study and characterize morphologic
features
as a summary today I introduce you the
application advantage of Multiplex if
assay using multi-mix as an example
the multi-obics enables staining for of
up to 60 proteins from one single
section
it's a powerful tool for immune
phenotyping and spatial integration of
tumor microenvironment
today we have focused on are the assays
to detect protein marker and expression
the platform can actually also be
integrated with other
Technologies such as RNA scope on fish
and by this integrated approach can
generate more data from one single
section
so with this summary I would like I will
end my presentation today and thanks a
lot for your attention